can you tell some of these stories that
stand out to you
that are particularly despicable or
representative or interesting when you
look back at that that defined
your approach and who you were at that
time let me say that i did not care
about my victim
all right i cared about me
is what i cared about um it's rough to
it's rough to admit that
you know that uh
you don't give a [ __ ] what you're doing
to anybody else you only care about you
but that's that's the truth of the
matter i didn't care about the victims
the lady that was that wasn't even at
the beginning of my
career as a cyber criminal that was
right at the last of it which lady the
coin lady i was uh by that point shadow
crew had made the front cover of forbes
august of 04
october 26th though for secret service
had to shut us down 33 people arrested
six countries in six hours
i was the guy that was publicly
mentioned as getting away um what
happened was is i was the guy who was
i'd
kind of invented this crime called tax
return identity theft and
was stealing a lot of money
i went through all my stateside savings
and shadow crew gets shut down i don't
have any way to come in with any money
so i start running counterfeit cashiers
checks
defrauding people without having them
send products or bullion collections
what have you buy cod collect on
delivery and i would pay with it with a
counterfeit cashier's check this lady
was on ebay
she had been collecting these silver
coins all of her life you know the u.s
currency used to be the coins used to be
silver so she had a whole collection of
these things like i don't know 80 90
pounds of this stuff
and
i'm a very good social engineer
so
convinced her that i was a legitimate
person that
you know hey send it to cld you can use
my fedex account to do that for my ups
account to do that i'll pay with a
cashier's check
you can take it in same as cash
she believed that she was
even on the ad and we talked on the
phone and everything else she had told
me that she would she was a single
parent and it was the only money that
she had to
to put a roof on the house for her kids
and uh i didn't give a damn i didn't
give a damn what was more important was
me at that point can i ask you a
question about the social engineering
aspect so maybe specifics like
the methodology email you said phone
maybe you could discuss
this process
from a bigger philosophical perspective
of
what is it about human beings that makes
impossible to be social engineer to be
to be victims of fraud so
first let me say that that i became a
social engineer as a child
all right because the adults in my in my
environment as a child i had to know
exactly what they were thinking and be
able to try to manipulate that for
survival so i became a social engineer
as
for for survival initially all right and
one of the things that i've seen with a
lot of cyber criminals is the exact same
thing they're really expert ones they
become a social engineer as a child then
later on they use those tools to
victimize others all right which is
fascinating because you're in order to
understand what others are thinking you
have to be extremely good at empathy so
you have to like
really put yourself in the shoes of the
other person and yet
in order to do cybercrime you have to
not care
about the pain
that might cause them once you
manipulate them so you have to empathize
and yet not care
exactly and i would argue i would argue
that that is not a sociopath because a
cyber criminal and i was no different
most cyber criminals justify those
actions so the justification becomes
what's important with me the
justification was why i did it for my
family
did it for my wife did it from a
stripper girlfriend yeah so and i
believed those justices
because i care about love a lot yeah so
the the big
the big picture of that
is trust
how do you establish trust
with a potential victim
all right now i would argue online that
that trust is established through a
combination of technology tools social
engineering all right so we trust our
tech
you know we trust our cell phones we
trust our laptops a lot of times we
don't understand how they operate but we
trust the news that comes across the
line we trust the phone numbers that
show up we trust ip addresses if we're
advanced enough to look at an ip address
or a domain or anything else like that
criminals use tools to manipulate that
spoofed phone numbers spook browser
fingerprints
or whatever that may be whatever the
tool may be then that lays a base level
of trust at that point you shoot in with
the social engineering
and lay whatever story that is in order
to manipulate that victim to act not out
of reason but out of emotion all of a
sudden
this is fascinating about the way humans
interact
with the world which is
you're almost too afraid to not trust
the world you have to find a balance you
have this uh you have a lot of sort of
conspiracy theories now
about this trusting institutions and
thinking like everything around us it's
like i've been listening to uh people
who believe the earth is flat
and you know that that conspiracy theory
is fascinating to me because it
basically says that you can't trust
anybody right
like everything you hear is a lie so
that's one you know you can live that
life or you can live a life where you're
just naively trusting everything and we
as humans have to because that life is
kind of full of happiness if nobody
screws you over right because you you
know you meet people with the joyful
heart and you get excited and all that
kind of stuff but if you do that too
much you're going to get burned so you
have to find some kind of balance in
terms of optimizing happiness
where
you
trust
i mean
but verified and on the internet that
becomes really tricky you're almost too
afraid to distrust everything because
you'll never get anything done right on
the internet but then if you trust too
much you can get screwed over and so
the social engineering comes in where
you're like i'm not sure if i should
trust this
you kind of help them
build the narrative was like it's good
it's good it's good
so and a lot of the times that social
engineering is just feeding into
what the victim wants to believe yeah
all right it's it's not really coming up
with a brand new story at all it's just
knowing what that victim is what the
motivations of that victim is
feeding into it at that point so you
have to again that social engineer has
to
almost immediately know what's driving
that person that they're talking about
if i'm so if i'm working on a phone
talking to someone over the phone i have
to know within seconds
what i need to say how i need to act to
interact with that customer service
agent or whoever i'm talking to i know
they're in the line so fascinating
because you truly are empathizing with
the other person um what is it this this
businessman stephen schwartzman um
uh i've talked to a few times
he mentioned this thing that you know
the way you build deep relationships is
you
really kind of notice the things that
people are telling you like
like what what they want and uh
what they're bothered by what are their
big problems in their lives because
everybody's saying that all the time and
most of us are just ignoring it right
you really take the time to listen
you know somebody at that point yeah
absolutely you do then you have to be
able to dismiss it
dismiss it after you know you're you're
looking for that just to see how i can
manipulate that is what you're trying to
do
so that the the lady was one story
another truly despicable story we'll get
to script in a second yeah but uh
another truly despicable story we had
we were one of the really first groups
that started phishing attacks so
phishing so that is a social engineering
attack ph by the way yeah ph that's
another social engineering attack that's
sending that fake email out that looks
like it's coming from a website or your
financial organization or whatever and
saying hey we've got a security problem
we need you to update your account
information
well back then
no one had ever seen a phishing attack
so you could ask for all the information
you were getting just complete identity
profiles on a phishing email nowadays
you can't do that nowadays you look for
basically credentials because everyone
is aware of phishing
but back then it was complete
information we had uh fished out i don't
know 200 000 e-trade accounts
that's what we have the login login
password yeah login password complete
you know social date of birth mother's
maiden
account information everything else
so we had access to those e-trade
accounts e-trade initially had no
security in place so you could cash out
the account ach the money out to whoever
to whatever account you wanted to went
through just fine
ate them alive on that for four to six
months
e-trade got to the to the point
where they you couldn't do any ach
coming out you know you they locked
everything down well you're still
sitting on thousands of e-trade accounts
how do you make money on that
that's a good question yeah so what you
do is you find some fat cat that's got
his retirement
you know invested in blue chips same
time you find a penny stock
you open up a brand new account buy into
that penny stock cash the fat cat out
buy into that same penny stock
pump and dump schemes all of a sudden so
you're destroying people's retirement
accounts
for just a few thousand dollars
bam bam bam and of course e-trade's
response is not our problem
it's your problem you shouldn't give up
your password or what have you at that
point and you still see that issue today
with zell scams and things like that
which scam zell so you know the instant
payment that that so it's the same kind
of operation some type of different uh
mechanism you you find an easy way to
export a system
and typically the financial organization
not our problem our system's secure it's
the humans it's their errors well
not really you know you've got some
culpability in that and you're just
trying to avoid
paying the part of the bill that's
what's going on one of the things just
to stand fishing for a bit is um
it really makes me sad because
there's been people on all kinds of
platforms like
including youtube comments but emails
too they figured out emails somehow
so people are
now
seeing the followers
um of this particular podcast where fans
they're finding them on platforms like
linkedin and youtube and so on and they
are figuring out ways to get to those
people by another channel right which i
suppose is
it seems more authentic to those people
so they send them an email from what
looks like me
and with this cut like like loving me
it's the the interesting thing the email
sound like something i would write
so these aren't even at this stage it's
not even it doesn't feel automated or if
it's automated it's uh there's a human
in the loop that's really fine-tuning
the specific or maybe i'm very
predictable but it's very loving in the
way i would write a message well and so
so so think about that all right so so
when phishing first comes out
you could look at the language of the
text or the website and say yeah if you
if you were paying attention that that's
so okay so that's not an english speaker
who wrote that typically all right
but as as time as went on as as the
awareness of what a phishing attack
looks like
we have people that are sitting down now
and making sure that language is proper
it gets worse than that though if you
look at business email compromise all
right so the way a business email
compromise typically works is the
attacker
will find a payroll person find a ceo
he will he will fashion a spear phishing
email which is that's a phishing attack
that's targeting one specific individual
all right
so he'll fashion a spear phishing email
the way he does that is he pulls all the
information he possibly can
on that person all right that ceo
maybe
he'll
spear that ceo just to get their login
credentials to their email just to read
the emails and he'll he'll go in there
and he'll start reading all these emails
he'll specifically read the emails to
the to the payroll department see what
that relationship is are they talking
about their kids talk about
relationships talking about vacation
what are they talking about how are they
talking are they friendly are they
sterile what are they doing all right
so then he decides well i'm going to go
ahead and spearfish this the payroll
department is good
so then he spearfishes them gets those
credentials at the same time he creates
a unicode domain in whatever the company
name is all right so instead of that
english alphabet i he's got that russian
letter that looks like an eye but
without the dot on top all right
comes back into the email into the
payroll email
blocks the real ceo's email replaces
that with the unicode email that he's
got and then sends out
a message using the correct language the
correct relationships everything else
and says hey you know we're updating our
account status i need you to send this
payment instead of over here
they've set up a new account send all
payments over here now and that is
business email compromise in a nutshell
all right works great
probably the larger the organization the
more uh susceptible to that kind of
attack because there's a um
like a distribution of responsibility to
where you're more likely to believe that
okay this other person is responsible
i'm sure they they uh secure that
absolutely i should i'm okay listening
to this
so that that's business email compromise
and it's it those crimes and that's one
thing you see about cybercrime
cybercrime's not really sophisticated
it's not the attacks are not
sophisticated the stat is 90 of every
single attack
uses a known exploit it's not the stuff
it's not zero-day attacks yeah they're
out there but if you're a criminal
waiting on a zero date of profit you're
going to starve to death
the the meat and potatoes are that 90
known exploits and then the rest is
well you're saying it's uh
maybe you mean it's not technically
sophisticated but it's social
engineering sophisticated very
sophisticated on that end very
sophisticated it's a fascinating study
of that establishment of trust and then
using that trust
to defraud that victim
that is something
you